I'm not a serial Irish a mile turn left
she sounds like she gets a grip when you
don't burn that wood Bobby is the
interior designer extraordinaire on
Netflix hit show queer eye today we have
some audience questions on how to make
their spaces better thanks for sending
these at cuz I won't be too harsh hello
my name is Abbi I am in my craft room
right now I would love that help making
my craft room feel more creative and
inspiring what I would recommend is
paint something cool well if you're not
like a good painter do like a geometric
you know square circles triangles those
are always very easy doing like cool
bright colors I think that would
definitely make it feel more inspiring
and more of a creative space my name's
Rebecca this random room in our house
has a fabulous view of our backyard but
nothing we do with it sticks now it's
just extra space for our new baby stuff
it also opens up to a backyard where we
let the dog out so bedroom is not the
best option if it has space for the
outdoors it definitely make it a space
where you can appreciate the view of the
outdoors put a nice little sofa or chair
make it a little reading room maybe a
fire yeah definitely for a nice little
martini in the afternoon and a good read
my husband and I just moved in to our
own place and it's a basement and I
would like some tips on making it feel
more homey less 70s and not feel as a
jar I actually like the room I think it
looks groovy but if you're wanting it to
not feel so dark I would paint the walls
white it will really open up the space
maybe keep the bar there though so that
way it adds a little bit yeah we're
friends I'm Natalie
interior design question is not excising
the space I have in my kitchen slash
dining area that's all creative one
thing I would probably do mounted
cabinets up on the upper wall so that
way you can still set up the dining
table that you have upper storage it'll
actually make the room feel larger cause
it'll draw your eye out I live in a
university presidents all of our rooms
look like ugly jail cells looking for
ways to brighten my room and make it
feel like home my advice in dorms is
removable wallpaper because most dorms I
know that won't let you paint it's a
good way to give it some personality
make it feel more like home without
getting in trouble with the school I
want to maximize my face so I can have
friends come over and visit autumn is
it's a micro efficiency measuring under
150 square feet you can always have
friends over though I would move the
desk over a little more towards the bed
and it won't double as a desk and a
nightstand and then under that window I
would do a storage bench with a cushion
on top and that way it adds storage in
your small place but it also makes for
basically a so focal point I love that
my name is Bailey thank you so much for
taking the time to listen to my sad
decorating woes
I've always been bad at decorating or
knowing anything about how to make a
house or a home the only thing I refuse
to take down with my Irish flag yeah but
please for the love of all that is holy
please help I would actually hang the
flag over the bed kind of make it as a
headboard get some bedding that
coordinates with the flag if you're
gonna go for it go for it because Irish
themed yeah I feel like every time I get
any bedding it makes me just feel
happier in my friend that is something
you should splurge on you want to wake
up feeling happy you want to go to bed
feeling happy spend a little extra money
on good bedding don't be fooled by the
whole thread-count thing it's not real
it's an American marketing ploy if it
feels good it's good if it doesn't feel
nice no matter how many thread count or
how expensive it is it's not bad thank
you so much I where can people follow
you on your social you can follow me at
Bobby Bourke
on Instagram or Twitter be sure to check
out Bobby and let us know if you have
any more questions
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel on your
part
subscribe here was my part
[Music]